Спершу збирав гроші на автомобіль, потім - на його розмитнення.
Киянин Антон власник так званої "євробляхи".
Купив автівку в Литві півроку тому за 1700 євро. Думав зекономити та - не вийшло.
Нині напозичався грошей, аби встигнути розмитнити автівку за пільговими тарифами.
Не думав про розмитнення. Просто вийшло, що як тільки я купив машину, так закон одразу і вийшов.
У моєму випадку це така собі підстава.
Підстава, бо я б з радістю рік-два покатався без цього закону.
Після масових протестів "євробляхерів" уряд запропонував компроміс:
до 22 лютого машини з єврономерами можна було розмитнити,
сплативши лише 50 відсотків акцизного збору.
До травня розмитнення коштуватиме повну ціну.
А з тими, хто не розмитнить авто до кінця травня, держава почне боротися штрафами.
Від 170 гривень за перевищення строку перебування в Україні на одну добу
до 170 тисяч гривень - якщо понад місяць.
За рішенням суду, автомобіль можуть також конфіскувати.
Перевірятиме "євробляхи" на вулицях міст патрульна поліція,
вона ж одразу на місці й виписуватиме штрафи.
Для цього у відомстві організують сервіс, який дозволить обмін інформацією
між фіскальними органами, Державною прикордонною службою та Національною поліцією.
Адвокат Вадим Володарський каже: такі кроки є виправданими.
Коли водій такого автомобіля залишає місце ДТП,
то фактично встановити його особу - досить проблематично.
І таких випадків дуже багато.
Власне, це й було однією з причин, чому все ж таки були ухвалені такі нові правила:
люди будуть змушені або ці автомобілі розмитнити і зареєструвати,
або нестимуть відповідальність за експлуатацію не зареєстрованих в Україні автомобілів.
Аби встигнути розмитнити автівки за пільговими умовами,
українські митниці почали працювати цілодобово.
Втім, черги меншими не стають.
Все тому, що водії кинулися розмитнювати "євробляхи" саме в останні тижні.
На київському митному посту "Західний", приміром,
на початку лютого розмитнювали близько 70 автівок на день,
а в останні дні пільгового розмитнення - більше 350.
Навантаження є, воно має місце.
Але ми працюємо, і люди повинні отримати те, що вони бажають,
а митниця - створити умови і вони створені.
За підрахунками Державної фіскальної служби наприкінці 2018 року
в Укарїні знаходилось від 500 до 700 тисяч "євроблях".
За пільговий період розмитнили 200 тисяч, тобто десь третину.
Антон припускає, що багатьом українцям не вигідно це робити.
Адже ті купували старі автомобілі вартістю від п'ятисот до півтори тисячі євро.
За пільговим тарифом чоловік зекономив 400 євро на акцизах, але разом з тим сплатив мито,
ПДВ, послуги брокера та штраф за порушення транзитного режиму.
Тож, сплатив в український бюджет суму, яка майже дорівнює вартості самої машини.
Негативні емоції, негативні, в тому випадку, що ніби цей закон мав бути легкий
і його подали під таким виглядом, що це легко, що це доступно і що кожен може собі це дозволити.
Але там все зроблено досить красиво з акцентом на нові автомобілі.
Тим не менше, автівок з єврономерами візуально стає менше, принаймні на київських дорогах.
Що не розмитнили, те перепродали на деталі або ж вивезли назад за кордон, припускає Антон.
Для нього епопея з "євробляхою" завершиться вже зовсім скоро.
За кілька днів має отримати українські номери.